hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer friesen TV and
we're here at maker faire in san mateo
california right outside San Francisco
looking at the maker movement how it's
really involved in recent years and why
it's enabling a much more individualized
society a maker is someone who takes
their skill of their hobby their passion
and extends it into actually creating
things traditionally to make a movement
started as you know non electronics
there's more and more people getting
involved in using electronics to make
art to make products that can eventually
actually be launched it's very
satisfying to come up with something
that you're passionate about using your
skills to create what with whatever it
is and not be bound by requirements of a
customer or someone else's demands you
can't ignore the DUI thing because a
good idea could scale up to full
production in a year every week Steve
solving robot which in solve a Rubik's
cube in any orientation and any scramble
it's my injection molding machine that I
made it took three years and I made
everything about this from the machining
the welding the design like literally
everything every part on this was made
with my hands I consider myself a maker
because I like creating things and
constantly every day I think of an idea
or something to make and I think making
is fun so when you think making is fun
and you can
ideas all the time that kind of
considers you a buzz maker I've always
been a tinkerer I've always you know
pulled stuff apart repurpose it redo it
and make it better it was just really
exciting to see this thing that started
out as an idea in my head it went to a
design and CAD and then it came out as a
real thing and so it's just it's a you
know it's a sort of sense of
accomplishment and just being able to
say that you did something you know 100
yourself I think that making technology
more accessible allows not only these
expression ideas which is evil to the
lofty goal the maker movement but a lot
of these makers or D wires are trying to
do something that perhaps someone like
myself in industry has become too jaded
the nice thing about these platforms and
the customizability is it becomes really
easy to rep reported type with hardware
we know has allowed people to take a
microcontroller do complex things
without actually knowing how to use a
microcontroller there's just more people
who have the idea will actually do it
you know because there's so many tools
from 3d printing a lot of like the mills
and electronics and Arduino is it's just
so much more accessible like before
there was such a barrier to learning how
to do stuff projects like Kickstarter
have enabled makers to actually become
manufacturers prior to you know the rep
reported typing platforms
it wasn't really possible to go from a
maker to a manufacturer because you
needed to know the vendors that actually
provided the stuff it was very hard to
actually get a product made that has
become really really easy you can do it
at every level I mean that's the cool
thing about this place there's so many
projects from just little fabric
electronics to smaller robotics it like
no matter what your skill level is
there's something that you can do I
think it's gotten a lot more popular I
was really little um when I was like
crackers a little uh way less people not
like i minored in 50,000 like there is
this year almost exponentially is a term
that's maybe overrated but I be coming
to the maker faire since it started in
the bay area and just the size has
expanded one of the other things as I
visit maker maker spaces is the sense of
community among its a really birds of a
feather and it is kind of infectious